>> I THINK THE LACK OF CHINESE
TRANSPARENCY IS THE REAL STORY
HERE.
IT CLEARLY EXACERBATED THE
PROBLEM AND MADE ITS
DISTRIBUTION AROUND THE WORLD
DRAMATICALLY MORE LIKELY.
>> Ed: THAT OF COURSE IS
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER
MITCH McCONNELL AS AMERICA
RATCHETS UP PRESSURE ON THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY HOLD,
HOLDING THE THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
THEY HAVE LAUNCHED A CAMPAIGN TO
PUNISH CORONAVIRUS PATIENTS AND
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS.
THE GOVERNMENT IS TARGETING
PEOPLE WHO REPORTEDLY ARE
CONTRACTING NEW CASES, SPEAKING
ABOUT BEING INFECTED OR EVEN
TRYING TO MOURN THE DEATH OF A
COVID-19 PATIENT.
GILLIAN TURNER IS LIVE IN
WASHINGTON WITH MORE.
>> WE HAVE LEARNED THAT THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT HAS INDEED
LAUNCHED A CRACKDOWN TARGETING
CORONAVIRUSSURVIVORS AS WELL AS
MEMBERS WHO HAVE LOST LOVED ONES
TO THE PANDEMIC.
NATIONAL SECURITY SOURCES TELL
US THIS IS THE LATEST IN THE
COMMUNIST PARTY’S ONGOING
EFFORTS TO COVER UP THE EARLY
DAYS OF THE OUTBREAK.
INSIDE OF THE CITY, WHICH IS THE
EPICENTER AS WELL AS THE TRUE
EXTENT OF THE VIRUS SPREAD
ACROSS THE REST OF CHINA.
THE CRACKDOWN AGAINST THE
BEREAVED INCLUDES ONLINE
CENSORSHIP, SHUTTERING DOWN
SUPPORT GROUPS, POLICE
INTERROGATIONS AND EVEN THREATS
AGAINST LAWYERS WHO ARE
REPRESENTING CHINESE VICTIMS.
SECRETARY OF A DEFENSE EXPERT
SAYS IT’S ALL PART OF A VERY
CLEAR PATTERN TO TRY TO SAVE
FACE AT THE EXPENSE OF PEOPLE’S
LIVES.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> THEY NEED TO STILL ALLOW US
IN TO TALK TO THE CHINESE
RESEARCHERS AND SCIENTISTS AND
TO HAVE ACCESS.
WHAT ARE THEY DOING?
THEY ARE TRYING TO CAPITALIZE ON
THIS BY PROMOTING THEIR OWN
IMAGE AND SOMEHOW CHINA IS THE
GOOD GUY HERE.
>> THE CRACKDOWNS ARE
PARTICULARLY TOUGH INSIDE OF
WUHAN, THE OUTBREAK OF THE VIRUS
BACK IN DECEMBER IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WAS FIRST
TO REPORT THAT OFFICIALS THERE
HAVE ALSO BEEN PAYING OFF FAMILY
MEMBERS TO THE TUNE OF 420 U.S.
DOLLARS PER MEMBER LOST TO THE
PANDEMIC.
CHINA’S AMBASSADOR TO THE U.S.
IS PUSHING BACK TODAY AND A NEW
OP-ED AND HE ACCUSES U.S.
POLITICIANS OF SCAPEGOATING
CHINA IN ORDER TO DISTRACT FROM
THEIR OWN FAILURES.
HE WRITES BEHIND THE MIND-SET OF
ALWAYS BLAME CHINA IS A KIND OF
DIRTY POLITICS CHAMPIONED BY A
FEW WHO SHIFTED THE SPOTLIGHT
FOR POLITICAL GAIN.
AS THE U.S. AND INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY RAMPS UP PRESSURE ON
CHINA’S GOVERNMENT ON THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY TO COME
CLEAN AND BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS, OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY SOURCES SAY
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT REMINDER TO
POINT OUT TO FOLKS, THE CHINESE
PEOPLE AND CHINESE CITIZENS ARE
ALSO HUNGRY FOR ACCOUNTABILITY
AND FOR THE GOVERNMENT TO
ACCOUNT FOR HOW THEY MANAGE THE
CRISIS DURING THE EARLY DAYS OF